CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU, BORIS.
IT'S SO GOOD TO BE WITH YOU AND
STUCK WITH EACH OTHER.
MOSCOW SAYS THREE PEOPLE WERE
KILLED IN TODAY'S MASSIVE
EXPLOSION OF THE ONLY BRIDGE
CONNECTING RUSSIA WITH THE
ANNEXED TERRITORY OF CRIMEA.
NOW, THE BLAST PARTIALLY
COLLAPSED THE KERCH BRIDGE AND
PARALYZED A KEY SUPPLY ROUTE
FROM MOSCOW'S FALTERING WAR IN
UKRAINE.
>> BUT THIS BRIDGE ISN'T JUST
LOGISTICALLY IMPORTANT, IT'S
ALSO A HUGE SYMBOL FOR THE
KREMLIN IN ITS ATTEMPT TO
REUNIFY CRIMEA WITH THE RUSSIAN
MAINLAND.
UKRAINE HAS NOT CLAIMED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS, BUT
AFTER THE BLAST IN KYIV, PEOPLE
CAN BE SEEN TAKING SELFIES IN
FRONT OF A BILLBOARD DEPICTING
THE IMAGE OF THE BRIDGE ON FIRE.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY THING YOU'RE
SEEING FROM UKRAINE MOCKING THE
EXPLOSION.
FRED PLEITGEN JOINS US NOW.
FRED IS IN KYIV.
HE HAS THE LATEST DEVELOPMENTS.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING, FRED,
ABOUT WHO'S BEHIND THIS
EXPLOSION.
>> Reporter: YEAH, WELL, THE
RUSSIANS ARE MOVING VERY QUICKLY
TO POINT THE FINGER OF BLAME AT
THE UKRAINIANS.
THIS IS QUITE INTERESTING
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING A
LOT OF TELEGRAM CHANNELS COMING
OUT OF RUSSIA.
A LOT OF TOP RUSSIAN POLITICIANS
ARE ALREADY SAYING THE
UKRAINIANS ARE BEHIND THIS.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE LAUNCHED AN
INVESTIGATION.
THEY'VE ACTUALLY PUT OUT A VIDEO
OF THE INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE
APPARENTLY AT WORK ON THAT
BRIDGE.
AND THEY SAY THE INITIAL
ASSESSMENT WAS OF A TRUCK THAT
EXPLODED.
YOU CAN SEE THAT MASSIVE
EXPLOSION TAKING PLACE.
APPARENTLY, A TRUCK DRIVING
THERE BEFORE THAT EXPLOSION TOOK
PLACE.
A TRUCK BLEW UP AND THAT CAUSED
PARTS OF THE BRIDGE, THE
AUTOMOBILE PART OF THE BRIDGE,
TO COULD ASP AND ALSO DAMAGE THE
RAILWAY BRIDGE AS WELL.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY'RE
SAYING, THERE WAS A TRAIN GOING
PAST THERE THAT APPARENTLY AS
HAVE FUEL TANKS IN IT.
AND AT LEAST THREE OF THOSE FUEL
TANKERS WERE DESTROYED AS THAT
EXPLOSION TOOK PLACE, OBVIOUSLY
LEADING TO THAT MASSIVE FIRE
THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING ALL
MORNING.
THE RUSSIANS ARE SAYING THAT
FIRE IS NOW OUT.
THEY ARE ABLE TO GET THE RAILWAY
PART OF THAT BRIDGE RUNNING
FAIRLY QUICKLY AGAIN.
BUT, OF COURSE, SEEING THAT
MASSIVE EXPLOSION ON OUR SCREENS
RIGHT NOW, THE AUTOMOBILE PART
OF THE BRIDGE, OBVIOUSLY,
SEVERELY DAMAGED, PARTIALLY
COLLAPSED.
GOING TO TAKE A VERY LONG TIME
TO GET THAT BACK UP AND RUNNING
AS WELL.
OF COURSE THAT IS A BIG, NOT
JUST SYMBOLIC BLOW TO THE
RUSSIANS.
THAT BRIDGE HAS HUGE SYMBOLIC
VALUE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE HIMSELF INAUGURATED THE
BRIDGE DRIVING A TRUCK OVER IT.
SIGNIFICANTLY, IN UKRAINE, IT'S
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT, THERE'S A
LOT OF HEAVY MILITARY GEAR THAT
WAS BROUGHT VIA THAT BRIDGE, NOT
JUST THE RAILWAY SECTION, BUT
AUTOMOBILE SECTION OF THAT
BRIDGE AS WELL.
SO, CERTAINLY, ANOTHER BIG ISSUE
FOR THE RUSSIANS AS THE
UKRAINIANS ARE ALREADY PUSHING
THEM BACK SEVERELY IN THE SOUTH
OF UKRAINE AND ALSO THEY'RE
SPACING MASSIVE LOGISTICAL
ISSUES AS WELL.
AS YOU GUYS HAVE ALLUDED TO,
YES, THE UKRAINIANS, ESSENTIALLY
SETTING SOCIAL MEDIA ON FIRE,
SYMBOLICALLY, IF YOU WILL.
TWEETING ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
MOCKING THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT.
IT CAME A DAY AFTER VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S 70th BIRTHDAY AND THAT
LED THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER OF UKRAINE TO TWEET A
VIDEO OF MARILYN MONROE SINGING
"HAPPY BIRTHDAY" OBVIOUSLY, JACK
KENNEDY BACK THEN AND OBVIOUSLY
MOCKING THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
WITH THAT.
WE'LL LISTEN FOR A SECOND.
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO Y